[Music]
in a recent interview Bernie Sanders
said he has a narrow path to the
nomination a narrow path the nomination
when asked how narrow Sanders III I bet
you I can guess the punch line of this
joke really Andy oh absolutely
okay that's great because it's time to
play
[Music]
[Applause]
I just I wanted to take a guess no not
this again please all right Andy I'm
gonna read that set up one more time and
then you'll have to why does it have to
turn into a game show why can't I just
say the punchline once again this set up
to that joke was in a recent interview
Bernie Sanders said he has a narrow path
to the nomination when asked how narrow
Sanders said as narrow as my peace dream
at two o'clock in the morning
I'm sorry any of that's incorrect
which means it's Lorraine's turn
Lorraine's the worst Kyle arein do you
think you can guess that punch line I
think so no seriously do we really have
to do this it is so annoying combined
Andy we're having a blast it isn't the
audience is irritated and I think
everyone hates Lorraine whoa whoa jeez
Andy what crawled up your ass well I'm
glad you asked Conan because it's time
to play
[Applause]
Bambi's asks I'm your host Andy Richter
contestants here's your first and only
question what crawled up my ass Conan
what crawled up my ass
a drunk raccoon looking for a place to
sleep no I I'm sorry that's not right
Game of Thrones creator and author
george RR martin what crawled up my ass
an entire khalasar of Dothraki horsemen
oh no I'm sorry
let's find out what crawled up my ass
with a little help from the bow-wow ah
[Applause]
Skippy spokes Bird the bottle out yep
let's find out what crawled up andy's
ass with my trusty colonoscope here we
go ready I am go oh look it's a cute
card guy and what's it say on the card
it says in a recent interview Bernie
Sanders said he has a narrow path to the
nomination when asked how narrow Sanders
said oh I bet I know the punch line to
that joke oh please no great cuz it's
time to play
[Applause]
all right Bernie Sanders said his path
to victory is as narrow as george RR
martin guess that punch line as narrow
as the one i took through the red sea
when my people left
[Applause]
that's terrific good for you George
Andy why don't you tell George what he's
won no I won't do it
Congrats George you've won a free annual
colonoscopy courtesy of the bowel
owl yay colonoscopy hell that's all the
time we have for punchline stamp
whatever Hotel they booked themselves
and Conan O'Brien's wardrobe provided by
Fellowes unlimited
you